Noah Goldberg tweeted out this photo of
an empty LA Times Newsroom apparently to
Garner sympathy you know he wanted us to
look at this and see see how empty it is
and be filled with mourning and grief
but I mean nobody reacted with sympathy
to that photo so sad Tim P had maybe the
best response which was quote this is
like taking a picture of a kitchen and
lamenting there are no roaches running
around which I think kind of sums it up
nicely then after the post was was
completely dog piled by thousands of
people Goldberg well I've gone viral
apparently among people who think the LA
Times is staffed by journalists who
advocate for white genocide and are
propagandists the oh yeah you think so
you just noticed that